a gunman who killed the son of a federal
judge may have also intended
to target a supreme court justice judge
esther
salas was in her new jersey basement
last year when a gunman dressed in a
fedex uniform opened fire at the front
door her 20-year-old son was killed and
her husband
was critically wounded the gunman and
attorney who had argued a case before
salas
later took his own life after the
shooting salus successfully pushed
for a new jersey law that safeguards
personal information
of judges and other officials 60 minutes
correspondent bill whittaker spoke to
salas
about a chilling discovery by the fbi
judge salas has become a crusader for
federal legislation
to scrub judges personal information
from the internet
her mission became more urgent when the
fbi
discovered a second locker in new jersey
belonging to her son's killer
what did they find what was in the
locker they found another gun
a glock more ammunition
but the most troubling thing they found
was
a manila folder with a workup on justice
sonia sotomayor
supreme court justice sotomayor yes
chilling what do you think you find that
a supreme court justice was on his
list more than on his list
on his sites stalking her like he had
stalked you
who knows what could have happened but
we need to understand
that judges are at risk we need to
understand that we
put ourselves in great danger every day
for doing our jobs
wow you know another one i remember that
story very well and listen it was
it was heartbreaking on many levels but
when you learn that that was their only
child their only child it made it even
more painful to me
it's heartbreaking for all americans as
well because you know
attacks on the judicial system are
something we're used to hearing about in
other countries
and to hear about it here is a sign of a
bad change of circumstances yeah and the
gunman literally went
right to their front door exactly you
know front door you can watch
bill whitaker's interview with judge
salas this sunday on 60 minutes
and judge salas will join us right here
monday
on cbs this morning